you talk about the Meuse as the source
of ideas maybe since you've gotten a few
glimpses of her in your writing tell me
let me what is it possible for you to
tell me about about her or did she
reside but what does she look like I
mean you can look at in many different
ways right the Greeks did it in an
anthropomorphic way right they created
gods or like human beings but if you
look at it from a Kabbalistic Jewish
perspective Jewish mysticism you could
say that it's the soul the neshama right
that the soul is above us on a higher
plane our own your soul my soul and it's
trying to reach down to us and and
communicate with us and we're trying
simultaneously to reach up to it to it
through prayer or through if you're a
writer or an artist you know when you
sit down at the keyboard you're entering
into a kind of prayer you're entering
into a different state of an altered
consciousness to some extent you're
opening yourself opening the pipeline Oh
turning on the radio to tune into the
cosmic radio station and another way of
looking at it this is Anna do you ever
see the movie City of Angels the visual
of the movie it was meg Ryan and Oh in
the game yeah yeah I've seen a hip and
right the visual of the movie sort of
was meg Ryan is a heart surgeon and as
she's operating on somebody suddenly
Nicholas Cage in this long duster coat
like Jesse James appears right next to
her in the operating room and he's an
angel and he's waiting to take out the
soul of the pray patient on the on the
operating table and she doesn't see him
she's totally unaware of him and so is
everybody else in the operating room
except maybe the guy who's about to die
who suddenly sees him but I kind of
believe that that there are beings like
that
or if you don't like that it's a force
it's a consciousness it's something that
are right here right now you know and we
and they're trying to communicate to us
and like through a membrane like tapping
on that window over there they're like
right out there and they carry the
future they are everything that is in
potential all the works that you will do
Lex your startup whatever else you're
doing they they know that and it's not
really you that's coming up with those
ideas in my opinion those things are
appearing you know it's like somebody
knocks on the door yeah
and puts it in I mean in the Iliad where
gods and goddesses appear along with the
human antagonists on the battlefield all
the time right they'll be you know Homer
flashes to Olympus and then back to the
real world and there's a thing where one
Aphrodite let's say wants to help Paris
and so she says well I will appear to
him in a dream and I'll take the form of
his brother and I'll say bumpety bumpety
bump so that's creatures beings on one
dimension as the Greek sought
communicating with and I believe that
that's exactly what's going on in one
whatever analogy you want to use but
that that communication to which degree
is do you play the role that
communication as opposed to sitting at
the computer if you're a writer and
staring at the blank page and putting in
the time and waiting what so if in your
in your view is are these creatures
basically waiting to tell you about your
future or is there choice
how many possible futures are there how
many possible ideas are that's a great
question I think there's basically
yes they're all alternatives you know
degrees within it but IFIF you look at
Bruce Springsteen's albums how much
could he have done really differently
yeah he would you can just see there's a
whole impetus well going through the
whole thing and nothing was going to
shake him off that you know and yeah
maybe the river could have been
different it could have been called
something else but but he was dealing
with certain issues his conscious self
was dealing with certain issues that
were really out of his control he was he
was drawn he was called to it right
nothing could stop him and so it is sort
of a partnership but I think the
creative process between the creative
impulse that's coming from some other
place or it's coming from deep within us
is another way to look at it you know
it's a like if we are acorns and and
we're growing then to Oaks so the
conscious per artist who's sitting there
at the keyboard or whatever is applying
his or her consciousness to that but is
also going into opening themselves to
the unconscious or to this other realm
whatever whatever that is I mean
certainly songwriters for a million
years have said you know a song just
came into their head right home just all
I had to do is right but then you ever
see that thing where of Keats's notes
for a thing of beauty is a joy forever
it's like covers an entire page that's
like you know he's crossing this out and
that out yet so though his consciousness
is his conscious mind is working on it
but I saw I do think it's a partnership
and I think that I know when I was first
starting out as a writer I worked in
advertising and I and I tried to do
novels that I could never do I was like
really unskilled at getting to that
tuning into that station I just beat my
brains out and was unable to do it you
know except and because I was sort of
trying too hard it was sort of
a Zen monk or a monk of some kind trying
to meditate and just like constantly
thoughts driving you crazy but over time
you know not would I've kind of gotten
better at it and I can sort of let go of
those that part of me that's trying so
hard and so these angels can speak a
little more easily through the membrane
can you put into words the process of
letting go and clearing that channel of
communication what does it take that's
like another great question for me it
just took I took probably 30 years and I
don't even I would I guess I would liken
it to meditation even though I'm not a
meditator but it would seem to me to be
one of the hardest things in the world
to just sit still and stop thinking
right and so it's very hard to put into
words and I think that's why these
teachers of meditation use tricks and
cones and stuff like that but for me at
least I think it was just a process of
years of years and years of trying and
finally of beating my head in the wall
and finally little by little giving up
the BET beating of the the head but this
doesn't seem to be any trick everybody
wants a attack these days and I don't
think there is a hack I look at it in
terms of the goddess the muse he's
watching you down there beating your
head in the ball you're like a marine
going through an obstacle course or a
martial artist trying to learn you know
like uma Thurman doing the casket deal
trying to make that little core its
punch you know the muse or the goddess
is just sort of watching on Lexi's turn
if you say I'm gonna come back in
another couple of months and see if he's
still there yeah and finally she'll say
alright he's had it he's beaten he's
paid his dues I'm gonna give it to him
you